[Musique]
c'est le drôle de conte de noël 2020 il
était une fois au pays des châteaux des
châtelains optimiste il avait réussi à
sauver leur début d'année avec une
saison d'été pas trop mauvaises et ont
commencé à préparer leur décor pour
fêter noël
mais cette année les visiteurs ne
viendront pas accès interdit pour le
moment
[Musique]
à chenonceau jean françois boucher
continue à faire des bouquets de fleurs
fraîches pour donner vie au château des
dames renoncules anémone amaryllis ryan
du blanc du rouge et quelques feuillages
d'argent on n'accueille pas mal de
deux magazines de déco et puis comme
tout a été mis en place au préalable
autant que ça serve épique les images
vives pour que certaines personnes
puissent le découvrir à travers la pièce
la presse ou les réseaux sociaux dans la
grande salle qui engendre le cheikh
seuls les gardiens et les salariés qui
ne sont pas au chômage partiel peuvent
encore ces merveilles après 25 ans c'est
un rendez vous manqué pour le public
chaque année c'est une thématique
différente pour justement créé ce rendez
vous avec évidemment l'art floral au
premier plan et comme on peut le voir
dans cette galerie l'art floral et ben
ça peut être 50 sapin puisqu'il ya
cinquante sapin dans cette dans cet
endroit donc c'est une forêt enneigée
dans une galerie qui est la salle de bal
de catherine de médicis
jean-françois met en scène son bouquet
dans un petit boudoir près de la chambre
de la reine
ils installent des coucous me étrange
petit concombre du potager tout autour
des paillettes et de la poudre magique
et à noël il faut bien sûr un petit peu
de neige
[Musique]
au château royal de blois au lieu du
pouvoir monarchique depuis louis xii et
de l'histoire de france depuis la nuit
des temps la mairie propriétaire des
lieux a investi beaucoup pour offrir un
peu de rêve
en cette triste période la salle des
états généraux est bleue comme le
plafond à fleur de lys l'idée c'était à
la fois de rappeler l'esprit de noël
avec le sapin qui est une coutume assez
ancienne qui date largement du moyen-âge
et en même temps d'avoir des sapins
multicolores puisque la caractéristique
des appartements royaux du château de
loi c'est la couleur
là encore pas de visiteurs les rois de
france n'est scolaires et tous les
autres circuler les sapins seront
démontées et offertes à des associations
caritatives
la conservatrice en chef et déçu triste
elle ne comprend pas pourquoi les
supermarchés et pas les musées les
premiers à partir
seront les sapins blancs ceux de la
chapelle à cheverny noël s'annonce et
gourmand enfants un traditionnel au
milieu de son calendrier de l'avent
géant constance attendaient avec
impatience d'ouvrir la case numéro 19
jours bénis de la réouverture prévue au
public
et peut-être sonné désespérant de voir
tous par toutes ces décorations toutes
ces illuminations
alors avec nous le soir comme on habite
le château on a la chance d'avoir ça
pour nous tout seul et on se dit c'est à
la fois un émerveillement et elle a
fallu une désolation à l'intérieur
tables de fêtes clin d'oeil souriant les
petits soldats de casse-noisette taquine
les chevaliers en armure on allait
pouvoir s'en mettre plein les yeux
à la sortie du confinement il faudra
attendre fin décembre janvier qui les
jours on continue d'oeuvrer pour que ce
soit dans le détail que tout soit fait
comme il faudrait que ce soit fait même
si on a zéro visiteurs donc voilà le
jour où on pourra appuyer sur le bouton
vert et ben appuiera est il sera prêt à
la nuit tombée le château offre un autre
visage
féerique demain comme tous les jours
cheverny ouvrira une nouvelle case de
son calendrier de l'avent et fêtera noël
le 24 décembre avec mélancolie
joyeux noël malgré tout